good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday hope
everyone had an amazing refreshing and
fulfilling weekend i really do i really
had an amazing weekend i don't know if
when you have an amazing weekend it
makes monday harder or it gives you the
joie de vivre to tackle this monday head
on i think it depends on what kind of
weekend you had if you had like an
amazing weekend having so much fun
getting so drunk like monday's rough but
if you had a really balanced
family-filled enriching
nourishing then i think that does give
you the power to power through our
monday i really do believe that yeah
well i did have the latter of weekends
but i just can't believe we're it's back
to the top you guys no i know because
like we were we were literally just
talking about this what a week ago like
back on the wheel back on the grind the
hamster wheel continues really
monday
again again
seems excessive yeah it's a lot we did
have a great weekend a jam-packed
weekend i saw billy joel you did which
was really um
it sounds like you i didn't see him on
the street okay i saw him in concert he
has like a residency at msg this is my
second time going and it was really just
it was spectacular i cannot recommend it
enough i think billy joel is extremely
underrated and i don't know if it's like
he's really a new york thing because he
exclusively plays in new york and he's
like huge in new york i don't know if
he's like
as popular in like nebraska you know i
think he's popular in nebraska and i
don't think he's underrated i think he's
a really big deal no i think he's
extremely underrated like i don't ever
see him like getting awards you know or
like i think he's won all the awards i
don't think he like comes out with new
music i wonder if billy joel has any
grammys i'm sure he does uptown girly
does billy joel uptown girly girl
you'd be really surprised how many songs
you knew you know new york state of mind
piano man i may be wrong
i'm maybe crazy
um he does he has quite a lot okay i
feel better one two three four five oh
like
one two three four five six seven eight
nine okay that makes you feel better so
he's properly rated you think i love you
just the way you uh no but like i was
talking to my friends i'm going to billy
joel on friday they were like that's so
weird i'm like it's not like
you i'm like you don't even know and i
think a lot of people at least people i
spoke to confused billy joel with elton
john
because even ben was like does billy
joel sing benny in the jets i'm like no
that's elton john and ben the reason why
we went is ben is literally billy joel's
number one fan like he grew up in a
billy joel house got it i could use
billy joel with billy the comedian
crystal crystal yeah well one of them is
annoying and one of them's not so it's
actually not hard to confuse them got it
well i'm glad you had a great time yeah
it was really exceptional if you have a
chance to see billy joel like see it
it's really it's quite a show right
after you see gavin degraw and right
after you head over to the
morningtest.com and social media to the
patreon because oh yeah we recorded a
patreon episode yesterday a new theme
which is so fun and it's such a good one
we had you guys submit anonymously so
you could be as free as you wanted your
unpopular opinions and we went through a
lot of them and just discussed our
thoughts and it was just fun to like
talk about random subjects peanut butter
avocados dairy-free gluten-free
allergies question mark question mark it
was really a lot of hot takes some that
i agreed with and some that i like just
did not understand like i don't think
kelly clarkson's that great like what
yeah that was a lot to digest but it was
such a great episode there were so many
there were hundreds of submissions and
we probably got to 20. so we will
definitely do a part two and that's
going to be really exciting maybe part
three
maybe it's like a part 100 in each no we
could actually we got over 500
subscribers and i do think we did 20 of
them or 10.
literally we we just were so chatty like
yeah because you know what like what is
up with maroon 5 you know right they
were really thought-provoking takes yeah
and we had to dive into each one we
could dine out on this idea until the
end until the end of the year and you
know what i actually enjoyed really a
lot like the experience of recording
that episode yeah me too so we won't do
that but just know that there's that's
how many hot takes there were but it was
interesting to see people having the
same hot takes about something totally
random right like beyonce oh yeah or
peanut butter a lot of people like
really hate peanut butter no and like i
like that just could never be me no
get you a sweet treat that also like a
nutritionist would approve of like
what love it um and then yesterday we
had the absolute honor
privilege and joy of seeing the downton
abbey movie finally we took control of
our own destiny even though we had to
wait for them to give it to us right we
didn't go to the theater but we were
able to purchase it on amazon prime for
a very fair what 25 35 to own it which
if we went to the theater
us two bunch of snacks maybe a seat for
theo like would have been yeah about
twenty five dollars for one person yeah
yeah so i thought it was a bargain and i
thought the movie was heavenly like
really really extremely well done
extremely well done i liked it more than
i liked the first movie i liked the beat
and i liked the plots because there were
two big plots that could have each been
their own number they gave us a lot and
there were so many like full circle
moments i felt i don't want to spoil
anything but i just like had this like i
felt like the whole time they were
framing each scene like
i'm sure they were doing this like from
a bird's eye view of like what it means
from the beginning of the show because
at the end you can plug your ears for a
second you know we're gonna let's talk
about it in depth so if you haven't seen
the movie like skip ahead in the next
two three minutes okay so i just wanted
to say i don't even want to spoil the
end about you know what happens but
so they're filming a movie at downton
that's one of the plots and in the end
the extras they hired the servants to be
extras in the movie and so all the
servants are sitting at the dining table
playing great lords and ladies from the
1800s and the family is watching them
behind the camera and standing it's the
first time that the servants are at the
table and the family is standing and i
just thought that was a really nice
metaphor metaphor because also
throughout the years it's like the
servants have become family and it's
like no and the later you go in history
like that servants they do sort of that
culture like dies out yeah so it was
really cool to see it inverted like that
yeah i also felt like there was a couple
story lines that like came full circle
and like loose ends that were officially
tied up obviously the first is clearly
the dowager
um and then like just other people whose
like
journeys like kel came to a close okay
you know um i was thinking of it before
i went to bed enough branson oh no um
barrow
yes barrow got you know what did you
think about dominic west in the movie
okay so right when we started it jackie
was like remember dominic west is in it
and that like immediately ruined my
entire day um because i just like really
don't like him but i will say like he
was
kind of extraordinary like he first of
all i loved his character he was like
this good guy actor from america but
with british roots and i thought he was
really great and i and i think the way
they tied up barrow's storyline because
there really isn't
that many realities in which barrow who
was closeted could have like a happy
fulfill what he called an honest life
yeah and i think he got as close to that
as he'll ever get and i actually really
liked the ending for him yeah and i
thought dominic west i thought he was
really good and i thought that other um
american actress who was in the film dog
leash
i thought she was awesome i loved doggly
she was nice to have like a new face on
the scene plus dominic west but we've
already seen his face so many times and
i liked her character arc
and i really i really enjoyed it yeah i
felt like at the end of the show like a
lot of people's story lines like became
complete like edith and that's why edith
wasn't like a major
part of this movie because like her
future is set you know so i just feel
like a lot of people who are kind of
like hanging like i wonder what happens
to them they kind of got their happy
ending okay but mary's still hanging
where was henry talbot
why wasn't the actor in the movie like
they obviously didn't say you can't be
in the movie because they let everyone
in their grandma in the movie they let
carson's real-life wife come into the
movies yeah like obviously they wanted
him to be there this is an ensemble
thing he clearly didn't want to do the
movie and
i think it's time for the seven husbands
of lady mary crawley no i know i thought
maybe that's like the direction that the
film was going but it was not no it was
not but if we do get a third film which
i think we could even though i don't
know that this one performed so well but
it's just hard because i know people
didn't want to go to the movies it was
so good i thought like literally it was
so beautiful like i need to go to the
south of france we need to be in the
french riviera immediately immediately
what are we still doing here so um i
really hope that
it does like well on demand
and i think that it will because we were
talking about like the people who watch
downtown like aren't running to the
theaters yeah so i loved it yeah i loved
you too i do hope there's a third movie
where lady mary is divorced and
widowed you know because like divorce
isn't like she can't be widowed twice no
but divorce is
becoming
not commonplace
but happening yeah in the 1930s it just
like honestly what whatever the um
whatever the ending for mary is in terms
of her love life it's not gonna be good
because like she was meant to be with
matthew right and they had to go and do
that because he just had to do beauty
and the beast you know i mean he gave us
a lot no he's
a wonderful man yeah but i liked luke
brandon playing her you know semi love
interest brandon from confessions of
shopaholic plays mr bob we were like
watching we were like where is this guy
from and when you said it i was like yes
like literally scratched the itch it was
so good it was so good uh
so we need to circle back with her and
they could do another movie even though
a lot of people are set in their ways
but
you actually gave a really great idea to
have the little kids grow up a little
more and then they can be debutants
girls about town but that puts us like
five years from now and then the war is
really just looming well okay first of
all i don't think i said that i think of
someone else in the room yeah that
sounds like a good idea i definitely
didn't say it
and yes that's what we were saying like
it's now 1930 maybe 1931 like how much
longer can they go on until they reach
the holocaust which of course has to be
addressed right and like little sibby
we could have like little sibby being
like 17 18 being like rose right but
that's like eight years and that's the
holocaust
that would be like 1938 yeah we're
creeping and also it's world war ii for
britain so it's like it's blitzkrieg
it's a lot it's giving blitz it's a lot
so i don't know where they go from here
especially because they started in 1929
and i feel like they maybe ended in like
31 yeah because the baby was born yeah
and like looked pretty big
so i don't know i don't know either but
i'm open to it you actually i think this
was your idea also just attributing all
the good ideas to you that for the next
movie they should go to america
that was my good idea but we're creeping
into the depression and i don't know
that that that's that's the vibe i don't
think it's the vibe but they they they
should have done it like in the show
there needed to be something like the
downtown an american moment like a
summer in newport yeah yeah so what
you're saying is it's not the vibe stop
that is exactly what i'm saying how did
you know
um okay official downton recap
over
come back so we've got a great show
we've got five measly stories it's
monday we have a lot of people who went
through some deep dark [ __ ] over the
weekend and they are unburdening them
themselves in our unburden yourself
segment okay i look forward to hearing
what you guys have for us and i guess
without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
the new starbucks bia energy drink with
caffeine naturally found in coffee fruit
it's energy that's good it's a beverage
that is crafted from caffeine naturally
found in coffee fruit as well as
antioxidant vitamin c it includes three
delicious fruity flavors mango guava
raspberry lime and pineapple passion
fruit each 12-ounce can has 90 calories
and it contains 160 milligrams of
caffeine so if you're looking for a new
way to get energy and coffee has never
really been your thing check out the
starbucks by energy drink i love the
mango guava guava flavor it's really
refreshing we keep them in the studio
it's a great thing to drink first thing
on a dreary monday starbucks bia energy
drink is available online at grocery
stores convenience stores and gas
stations nationwide today's episode is
also brought to you by slaughter mania
life is too short without a day without
fun
get a thrill whenever you need it with
slotto mania the world's number one free
slot game you'll have endless excitement
at your fingertips with 170 free-to-play
slot games huge jackpots an interactive
community and a million free coins it's
a perfect escape from your daily routine
so there's nothing more exhilarating
than huge jackpots special prizes and
free coin rewards every day slotto mania
makes every day funtastic with engaging
graphics and realistic sound effects so
actually i downloaded sodomania from a
tick tock ad like a couple months ago
because i live for a
phone game i'm like a toddler and it's
really super fun to play you know guys i
love going to a casino so it's very much
the vibe and with added perks like free
spins and free coins there's always
something unexpected waiting when your
day is feeling stale just ask what will
today spin if you're 21 or older you can
join millions of players around the
world download slot omania the number
one free slots game on the app store or
google play store and get a million free
coins that's slot a mania on the app
store or google play store for a million
free coins
great also does dominic west's
performance in downton abbey make you
more okay or excited for him in the
crown as prince charles
like yeah but here's my question
is dominic west british yes i just saw
he was born in the orchard okay so that
definitely helps because the thing i
liked about downton it's like it's
protected from thirst monsters because
you have to be like organic too yeah and
also in the new downton movie was imelda
staunton who is going to be playing the
queen in the crown maud bagshaw who's
actually carson's real life wife and the
parents of one of the featherington
girls the irrelevant ones yeah yeah but
they are like they turn out to be kind
of cute in the end you know but it's not
not lady whistle no not not whistle down
yeah so um
dominic west uh
it's definitely better it softens the
blow i really did think he was great but
like something about him maybe it was
his character in the affair and then
that like weird lily james affair thing
which is also weird because lily james
was in downton abbey um that makes me
just like kind of icked out by him like
he gives the egg
yeah i hated the affair more than i did
i didn't even finish it
that's how and i went through a bunch of
seasons and i hated it so much i was
like i need to stop watching this is
making me angry i actually really liked
it of course there were things that made
me angry like watching the same episode
watching the same 30 minutes twice but
from two people's perspectives like how
much time do you think we have like
foreign conceptually it's an interesting
idea how he remembers it versus how she
remembers like he thought she was coming
on to him like she saw it as like he was
it's a good idea for one episode not for
a whole show yeah they stopped
eventually yes but um so there were
things i really didn't like about it
it's like uh allison's character and the
whole 30 minute thing but there were
things i really did like about it maura
tierney joshua jackson there were things
i really liked and i did finish it and
like did i ever tell you how it ended do
you want to know
uh no i yeah tell me okay spoiler alert
if you're in the middle of watching the
affair if you ever plan on watching it
i'm gonna spoil the ending okay
you're gonna die
they get back together
who the initial married couple the
affair
maura tierney and dominic west even
after the murder yeah and the baby yeah
and then i think she dies or something
because they like they fast forward to
the future and he like goes back to
montauk
and like spreads her ashes
it's so stupid so stupid no they really
lost me that season with brendan fraser
oh that was that was incredibly stupid
but justice for brenda frazier yeah
because like at the end of it he wasn't
he didn't even do those things no noah
was like going psychologically well yeah
um do you know about like the internet's
obsession with brendan fraser no
okay so like a couple of years ago some
random i think it was a podcast or
something somebody decided to interview
brendan frazier and everyone knows
brandon fraser when he was really young
and very handsome and like you know a
boy next door and then we kind of like
haven't heard from him really except he
wasn't the affair and he did this
interview um and he was just being so
cute he like looks he looks like a dad
now he just looks like p john material
and the interview went so viral like
especially on tick tock people literally
are obsessed with him he has like a
whole new career now because of his
internet fandom and what does he do with
it nothing he just engages with people
online all the time he like loves it
gives major dad energy i'm looking for
what podcast it was or like a web show
don't
don't quote me on well i think he has a
podcast now of course he does welcome or
it's called the brendan frasier podcast
and it's hosted by other people that
might be it
like it's other people have a podcast
called the brendan frasier like another
person named brandon fraser you know
just like people who are pregnant pretty
sure fans see i'm telling you i think
no there's something there i love
brendan fraser yeah they talk about
everything brendan fraser i'm telling
you he has like a crazy fan club and i
get it i mean i saw george of the jungle
and
what was that other movie with the phone
where he sells his soul yeah it was
elizabeth i think it was called like
bedazzled no that's what i was thinking
bewitched it's like no no brendan fraser
wait don't tell me i know it i think
it's really bedazzled it's it's like a
word exactly like bedazzled okay it's um
besmirched no no bewildered
it's with a b and it's like to dazzle
but it's not bedazzled what is it i'm
looking look up elizabeth bedazzled
bedazzled he sells a soul to the devil
and elizabeth hurley is the devil yeah
and he like he keeps making calls on a
phone to like get a new life or
something such a good move
okay now that we've recap brendan
frasier we can get into the fast side
stories and the first one is that amber
heard did gma or sorry the today show
this morning same thing and says that
she doesn't blame the jury for the
verdict she calls johnny a fantastic
actor
so amber heard doesn't blame the jury
for johnny depp's recent victory in
their defamation trial she said quote i
actually understand he's a beloved
character and people feel they know him
he's a fantastic actor she went on to
call the social media negativity
surrounding the trial unfair she said
quote even somebody who is sure i am
deserving of all this hate and vitriol
even if you think that i'm lying you
still couldn't look me in the eye and
tell me that you think on social media
there's been a fair representation you
cannot tell me that you think this has
been fair
okay i actually don't disagree with her
like and i feel like we talked about
this a lot throughout the trial like
what what social media was like
contributing
but
i don't think that has anything to do
with the verdict right social media is
irrelevant to the verdict and actually
because if the trial was if she thinks
the trial was fair and the jury did
their job if they had ruled
even if there was no social media taking
sides like once the jury ruled like then
that's what people would have
went with anyway i just
like i agree with the point she's making
but i don't see how it's relevant at all
because jurors are not allowed aren't
they kept in hotels they're not allowed
to engage in social media because that
would obviously be yeah
creating bias so i agree if you look on
social media and that's something i
think we all experience like when we
first started like dipping our toes in
the trial and it's like well there's so
much pro johnny content because johnny
has a lot of fans
and
was it really johnny's fans making the
content yes okay he has like
ravenous like but amber have a lot of
fans too like she
is an aquaman like she's also a big
actress it was like that one year she
was the most googled woman in the world
like just for her looks like like not
for anything tabloid like it was like
the most beautiful
thing yeah no she definitely should um
but i think and that was something that
they discussed during the trial were
like q scores and social media
followings of amber versus other people
in the marvel universe like gal gadot
like jason mamoa and what they
like what the that researcher
conclusion was was that like you amber
in comparison to other marvel and i
don't know if it's marvel whatever like
other comic book people
she had a much lower like likability
from social media from the public who
was putting this researcher on the stand
ambers people both people they both had
researchers um i think it was
amber's person
and then johnny had a a rebuttal because
amber's it was amber's agent basically
saying comparing her to gal gadot jason
mamoa zendaya and like maybe chris evans
in terms of like what they're getting
paid how amber was um just like them and
that's and johnny trying to get her
taken her he tried
amber alleged that johnny tried to get
her out of aquaman too and so amber's
witness on the test
amber's what is it called
expert was basically like well look at
what all these other people are doing
and he tried to get her fired so
you know that could have been her and
that's a damn that's considered damages
but then they had someone come on and be
like well actually she's not like
zendaya gagadot or jason momoa and
here's why here's her q score here's her
social media numbers and it was much
lower than gal gadot and jason mamoa and
kevin evans and zendaya got it which
honestly i don't think her agent should
have ever compared her to those people
because no but it's good because it
looks like they have all this and that
could have been amber too even though
like not at all they're not on the same
level no in each situation like gagadot
was wonder woman was a franchise aqua
woman yeah i guess a good comparison
would be zendaya no but zendaya is
indeed not because she's the leading
lady in spiderman because she's because
she's in there yeah like you could be
and shake it up
and then maybe call that's true no it's
like
get you a girl who can go from shake it
up chicago to literally can film
festival literally plus everything in
between greatest showman euphoria
spiderman where's that body of work from
amber yeah
so i don't really know i mean i guess
she had to do something
in terms of a response if she plans on
having a public life yeah so i think
this is a good first step but
i don't really um understand like the
relevance of the the point she's making
yeah and i also think that people are
either team johnny or their team amber
and if they are team johnny like they
see her in this light and interviews
like this just perpetuate what they
think that they see which is that she's
lying and that she's you know
changing the narrative that's actually a
fair point and the people who are team
amber are still team amber i don't know
that this will change any hearts and
minds i think if any hearts and minds
were going to be changed it was going to
be during the trial 100 now that's over
100 i think mines were changed in the
other direction yeah and so
yeah i i agree with amber like social
media was not in her favor and it wasn't
like a fair fight because johnny did
have this like you know huge fan base
but at the end of the day that has
absolutely nothing to do with the jury's
decision yeah
and you know i was thinking the other
day how we haven't had any jury
interviews book proposals like i was
waiting i thought literally the next day
there would be like a gma with one
thirsty juror you know yeah the first
two journey one thursday
but we haven't and i'm curious usually
we find out what happens like in the
in the room you know yeah was it
unanimous was it a fight but we don't we
haven't heard anything yeah we're the
thirsty jurors i don't know because
there's like a time
like maybe there's a statue of like they
can't talk for a few weeks i don't know
yeah or maybe like they miss their
families they're just taking a breath
they don't want to talk about amber and
johnny for five minutes
and
they'll they'll resurface yeah
we'll see we'll see but also in order to
be on a celebrity trial like this you
can't be interested in celebrity things
so i'm sure most of the jury members
like
don't want that life yeah i mean before
you go to trial especially with these
big fancy lawyers they spend literally
days going through people so i think
they had to ultimately have landed on a
group of jurors who aren't the biggest
pirates of the caribbean and aquaman
fans because that wouldn't be fair yeah
that's like
like an explicit bias yeah so
maybe like they in turn had to choose
non-thirsty jurors which is just a loss
for us yeah yeah
are you ready for our next story some
great news some great news jennifer
hudson became an egot winner last night
at the 2022 tony awards when she won for
a strange loop she joined the ranks of
the select few who have gotten all the
prestigious performance awards she joins
the exclusive list of 16 other winners
winners including the likes of audrey
hepburn alan menken andrew lloyd webber
and whoopi goldberg goldberg who all won
awards at the emmy's grammys oscars and
tonys hence egot okay so i didn't even
realize jennifer hudson was in the
running or else i would have like
actually like paid attention to
the tony like right because i know a
couple people who are almost there like
i know lady gaga's maybe halfway there
as of last night rupaul is halfway there
because he won a tony and he's won like
a million emmys i don't know how he's
going to get an oscar halfway there
it's not it's start it's just sure it's
a start but like i'm interested in the
three-quarters there yeah i think lady
gaga's three quarters i think so too so
i didn't know i was like keeping my eye
on certain people and i didn't even know
jennifer hudson was almost there and the
best part is like when you watch her she
won with an ensemble so she didn't like
make a speech or anything she was
standing with the group
and
you literally see her realize that like
oh my god it's the fourth one like i got
it i don't think she went into it being
like i'm gonna get an egot yeah it's so
crazy and she's so talented and this is
proof that you don't need to win
american idol you don't need to win
american idol i wonder if when you
become an egot you get a trophy for egot
no no because they're all separate
entities so there's no egot entity no i
think some people make necklaces
that's cute yeah
do you think there's like uh like a
yearly meeting of the egots
there should be yeah there should be i
feel like there definitely is and like
currently whoopi goldberg is the like
leader of it
yeah
well
i guess let's do what we love to do see
who's other this is yeah john legend i
know alan menken
love you know him who loves beauty and
the beast score do you want do you know
what he looks like you don't know i love
his work okay okay he did beauty and the
beast oh love love love um menkin we
love it i didn't realize i was a fan of
alan menken
oh audrey hepburn
whoopi goldberg john legend rita moreno
oh uh
what's that story yep mel brooks
rice unfamiliar
me as well me as well mike nichols
richard rodgers
rogers and hammerstein
ah
thank you i think no let's go with that
yeah jonathan tunic
marvin hamlisch
i think these are a lot of like musical
direction like behind the scenes people
like andrew lloyd webber right the the
the thread that pulls you know an egot
together is really music you can't just
be an actor and win all four because how
the [ __ ] you're gonna win a grammy so
people who get egots normally do
music for movies for tv shows for
theater yeah and
that's why it's mostly people you
probably haven't heard of but that's why
when like a forward-facing celebrity
wins it's like even more impressive yeah
yeah robert lopez it's interesting to
see all the um
like he wrote let it go and remember me
oh yeah those are from like the more
contemporary book of mormon john gilgud
and jennifer hudson and helen hayes good
for scott rudin and that's it that's it
that's it um this is like one of the
last few things i think that are like a
really big deal
you know because i feel like these days
you know everyone has an emmy you know
but like to have an egot is such
a big deal i think they should rebrand
like it's not enough to have an egot you
have to have a re-got a razzie as well
one razzy a hundred percent just to show
that you're able to flop and get back up
it shows the horse strength perseverance
courage right it shows that you can
laugh at yourself i'm interested in the
re-gots
this is huge like really this is maybe
one of your best ideas yet i actually
completely agree do you think any of
these people have razzie yeah yeah
a razzy is prestigious well razzies are
contemporary john legend
maybe has a reason
let's see
oh well cat's got a razzy and who was in
cash jennifer hudson
she is ree got
she's the first regatt winner
because i don't think the razzies were
around for audrey hepburn check if john
legend has a guy okay as a razzy
wow
john legend razzie wait here's an
article this is our sort of publication
two egot winners are also razzie winners
so there's two rigots there are two
wreaths does that include jennifer
hudson though because there may be three
then
uh let's see it is incredible
uh hold on hold on
it's like very verbal wordy
may alan menken has a razzy for the song
high times hard times from the musical
newsies and he got that the same year he
won an oscar that's always my favorite
when you get a razzy and oscar the same
year sandra bullock and who was the
other one who got um
a razzie
minnelli is that
liza liza but she wasn't on that egot
list
oh yeah this is an article about re-gots
whoopie goldberg is just one rosy win
away from gaining re-got status okay but
even though like it's an article like
you had the idea like i did i promise
you but i'm glad to know there's people
who think like me okay the re-god is
huge right no johnny
egot no thanks regat yeah
we got over greater than yeah that's
what i was we got
greater than
she's making fun of me she's making fun
of me okay wow congratulations jennifer
hudson like
you've won them all huge brava
are you ready for our next story justin
bieber's postponed two upcoming new york
city shows following ramsay hunts
syndrome diagnosis i'm sorry like you're
trying to tell me ramsay hunt is the
name of an illness and not someone from
game of thrones yeah
yeah that's shocking it's clearly a
nefarious name yeah
nothing good can come from ramsay
nothing justin bieber will not be
performing in new york city this week
amid his ongoing health battle the 28
year old singer who recently revealed
that he'd been diagnosed with ramsay
hunt syndrome was originally slated to
perform at the city's fame msg on monday
and tuesday but he posted to social
media a video and texting that he was
taking some time off of his tour to um
deal with some health issues including
ramsey hunts syndrome where half of his
face is paralyzed
i mean i'm
heartbroken i was literally supposed to
be getting ready for justin bieber right
now we're going tonight yeah oh nice i'm
so upset but obviously i understand and
i'm wishing him the best and you know
it's just like
scary it's scary also because this is
like a freak thing and i feel like
something similar just happened to haley
like she had like a freak stroke she had
a 25 year old healthy girl yeah
um and like these things just shouldn't
happen to young people and it's like
freak things um and i hope he's okay
yeah i hope he's okay too i don't know
really anything about
this syndrome like
how long no how it starts or anything
right uh so i just hope he's getting the
help that yeah i don't i don't think
it's permanent i think it's something
like that goes through you oh okay um
people have compared it to bell's palsy
a little bit again i don't know much
about that but i do think in the long
run he will be okay okay great but this
is like he canceled the new york ones
and he canceled once last week too so
it's like it's been a long thing
got it yeah and the justice tour was
going so well yeah at the eclipse it
looked jumpy i know
i was so ready like and you
are the only one i'll ever love i gotta
tell you gotta tell you i was so excited
like pumped oh i'm sorry i know well we
also didn't discuss how thrice is here
today yeah that's if you were listening
to the podcast you would never know that
theo was here today because he's being a
gorgeous angel and if you're watching on
youtube you can understand i don't know
why every time theo comes here he
insists on snapping his neck like lay i
don't know why he lays like he loves to
lay with his head like his full body on
the couch and head hanging off the edge
of the couch and it's like don't you get
sore yeah but he likes it who are we to
tell him i know but every time i go back
i know what judo's episode that he's on
it looks like he's not well but he's
okay maybe he's just holding a lot of
tension in his neck you know he can just
release it yeah it's a lot of work being
you know thrice to starve the family
yeah
bryce but together well no together
they're the stress brothers yeah it's
hard to be one half of the streis
brothers no and it's hard to be theo the
star
this the co-star
wow co-star the star are you ready for
our next story speaking of stars one of
your favorite in the galaxy is it my
favorite star in the galaxy that's
brought to you by
kitsch yes
when did beauty get so complicated so
much time too much money not enough that
works for you that's what we're talking
about on patreon yesterday that's why
kitsch was created to simplify self-care
and beauty products that give you a
major boost so you can go on to your
next thing they offer game-changing
time-saving beauty essentials for hair
skin and body at kitsch whatever your
budget your skin type your hair type
kitsch believes you deserve little
indulgences at affordable prices morning
noon and night so they started in 2010
and their best sellers include the satin
pillowcases caps eye masks satin that is
vegan and cruelty free not like silk
which was made from silk worms they are
really great for your hair and skin
while you sleep i recently got on this
the satin pillowcase trend um because i
got one from kitsch and i have to say
like my hair
no longer unruly when i wake up it's
game changing your skin yeah the
wrinkles on your face
they also have the shampoo and
conditioner bars which are bottle free
beauty which i've been seeing a lot of
people start using and i think it's
really great obviously it's a great way
to reduce plastic and it just like makes
a lot of sense so the shampoo and
conditioner bars are one of their best
sellers and the heatless satin curling
rollers you can say bye to heat damage
there are tick-tock videos throwing away
people have thrown videos of people
throwing away their 600 curlers for this
heatless curls are the new frontier yeah
so kitch is offering you 30 off your
entire order at my kitsch.com toast
that's right 30 off anything and
everything at my kitsch m-y-k-i-t-s-c-h
dot com slash toast that's my kitch.com
slash chose for 30 off your order i
highly recommend that satin pillowcase
it will change your life
great okay our next story taylor swift
surprises fans with a performance at the
tribeca film festival yes yes she did at
saturday's tribeca film festival
screening of all too well the short film
the musical multi-hyphenate was slated
to speak with director mike mills about
her foray into filmmaking but she
surprised guests by ending the afternoon
with a live acoustic performance like
obviously like what if she was she not
was she gonna do not perform yeah so she
performed all too well
uh extended version
and the fans were hiking yeah it was at
the beacon theater right which is just
really near and dear i heard like before
her mic was turned on she sat down and
she's like so you're saying claudia
ashley performed on this stage yeah i
heard that too but obviously i can't
confirm nor deny um
and so
first of all i love the all too well 10
minute video i think it's literally a
work of art i'm glad it's getting its
moment and it really just like this
whole taylor all too well movie thing
makes me just love sadie sync like to me
like she emerged the hero from this
whole thing because she's i feel like
she's always playing second fiddle to
millie bobby brown on stream do you
watch stranger things no but i've never
seen it no me neither but i know the
whole cast is famous and millie bobby
brown is like the most famous and it's
like well what about sadie zing and now
i'm glad sandy sink is having like her
special thing
yeah this is very special yeah it's a
huge honor
um what's that guy's name dylan o'brien
i like him too i didn't really like
think of him before but any friend of
taylor is a friend of mine dylan o'brien
from curb
who's in curb remember larry's trying to
get him to play young larry and he has
to like go to his concert and listen to
his music yes yes yes yes
um i also know him from he's from the
disney channel i'm pretty sure he's not
he's not he's from teen wolf
are you sure positive he's so disney
he's not disney you're right teen wolf
yeah
he looks like the brother from um and
he's in that that um franchise that was
like big
the commercial the amazing yeah sliding
through that cement door and he's from
the internship
which is the best movie not the one we
watched this weekend okay we also
watched the intern this weekend which is
just like one of nancy meyer's forgotten
films no it's like it gets so much
credit but like it's beautiful i never
choose to watch it because i've seen it
i know it's amazing but like watch it
again it's so amazing but no he's the
one with owen wilson and vince vaughn
which is actually my favorite movie and
he plays like the kid on the other team
who's like an [ __ ] yeah yeah you know
it's i didn't even realize there were
two iconic films literally with the same
name the intern and the internship no he
plays the person on their team who's the
[ __ ] but then of course heart of gold
of course you put them in a blender when
the team works together yeah they're
googly um
taylor looked great she's saying of
course i saw the performance it was
really quite breathtaking
beautifully beautifully she enchanted
her half torah portion beautifully yeah
we're so proud of you mazel tov
and it was a gorgeous afternoon in new
york city you know we don't get those a
lot no we really don't numb
so it was nice to see i hope she wins
for the film festival i don't think is
it a competition uh it should be i think
you're right because get a sparkle yeah
someone should win yeah like uh
something but also like is this a short
film that could be in contention at the
oscars and i got smelling and egot well
she was
nominated for cats obviously that didn't
win but that's giving really does she
only have g
she has g
l
a m
does she have anything other than a g no
um are you okay does she have an e i
feel like she was being an actress at
some point no
does she haven't but she might have
written a song is it a z shirt oh my god
are you okay is it an f shirt
i think she only has a g which would
mean she's incredibly far away and she
is an r for pretty close yeah but i do
think like this should be a short film
that's in contention at the o yes r o u
s
[Laughter]
it's just so fun i'm a big jack harlow
fan i know you are i just really like
that song i know even though it's like
not his song no but i also don't even
think i've ever heard the whole song i
just like hear it on no instagram and
also like from other people's radios
when i'm at a red light i could put you
in first class
up in the sky we're like such like rap
girlies such
are you ready for the final story yeah
speaking of music
you've got the music in me are you ready
for our fifth and final story yeah i'm
like kind of i don't really want to do
oh you don't want to sing the it's not
that i don't want to sing i'm just like
not in the mood to sing that particular
song today do you have a different song
in your heart
it's written in all of us and it's
brought us here because you are the
story in me gorgeous
our fifth and final story is that the
real housewives of new jersey star joe
gorga has gone off on one of his tenants
in a wild video saying that he hasn't
paid rent for four years joe gorgo went
nuclear on one of his tenants in a
rented speed over an apartment complex
the star owns and the screaming match is
intense the heated argument is a peak
jersey showdown with landlord joe
getting all up in the grill of his
tenant and profanities and accusations
flying in both directions the incident
went down thursday and it sounds like
this dispute has been brewing for a
while joe's lawyer claims the tenant
hasn't paid rent for a few years and
owes nearly 50 grand in back ran
backwards
sorry it's a rant about rent as you can
gather from the video the tenant sees
things differently claiming joe's gotten
a good chunk of rent many from the state
due to a coveted relief program while
joe's attorney says joe collected nearly
40 grand and coveted rental assistance
from new jersey he claims the guy hasn't
paid rent on his own since october 2018
and still owes the nearly 50 000 sum
joe's rep says joe initially felt bad
for the guy and didn't want to evict him
but as you can tell from this video
joe's had a change of heart uh his rep
says they've now filed eviction papers
for his part the tenant says he's a
restaurant manager who lost his job
during covid and is still trying to get
back on his feet
yeah um but if you haven't paid rent
since october 2018 and the pandemic
started in 2020 yeah i mean part like
how does it get to this place like i
feel like
aren't the rules like you don't pay rent
one month like you're out yeah but the
rules did change during covey yeah
october 2018 that's literally a year and
a half no totally so you couldn't evict
people during coven because they had
like a rent moratorium or something and
the eviction courts were closed which i
think was fair even though we happened
the eviction courts were closed but
somehow we got evicted from our old
office during coven right we're right um
but i think for joe like maybe if the
guy wasn't paying in 2018 like maybe it
was just more of like a relationship
where it's like okay you'll yeah you'll
get me back get me back next time but
now this is going on four years and it
seems as though joe's patience has worn
out yeah but like doesn't joe
first of all i didn't even know joe was
a landlord like right we're learning so
much about his business and honestly i
don't think i really understood what his
business was up until now um and two
like
doesn't he like run a big company like
shouldn't there be other people like
taking care of this yeah but they
clearly didn't take care of it right i
don't know how you let this go on for
four years yeah
and then you wind up on tmz no and like
the
and like
when i pulled up this story there was
like um
like a still shot from the video and
it's like someone in their car filming
joe with his phone filming and it's like
it's giving karen you know yeah and you
never want to be associated with like
that like if i ever i always think like
i will do anything in my power to avoid
ever getting into one of those videos i
like go viral on tick tock and youtube
like if there's ever like a moment on
the a plane where like i want to start a
fight like i won't just because like
that video will haunt me till the day i
die
and so joe kind of he has that now and
that's tough
yeah nobody wants a camera video
but is it the karen who's filming it
depends on the situation sometimes it's
the karen filming no totally but like i
just don't want to be associated with
any karen like videos you know even if i
even if i'm okay till i justify you
gotta get paid four years no pay yeah so
say like someone owed you four years of
payment like say like
i don't know what it could be miranda
okay
no like say you were working like for a
brand for four years and they wouldn't
pay you and your asians couldn't get the
money and like you needed to show up to
the offices and demand your money like
with the fear of having like a video an
unflattering video stop you from getting
what's yours yes actually i did go
through something like this with an
extremely large brand um
and this was a couple of years ago and i
literally was so [ __ ] annoying it's
like when you do an influence or
partnership usually it's like net 30 net
60 which means the brand has like 30
days or 60 days to pay you that's in
your contract whatever it's in your
contract mine was knits 30 but like
usually they pay you literally the next
week if it's like a normal brand that's
like easy to work with and this
particular brand i won't say because it
wasn't the brand's fault it was the
marketing agency and i would love to put
them on blast but i won't because i feel
like there are a lot of toasters who
work there
um
i was emailing non [ __ ] stop actually
i kind of want to find the email because
i was being so crazy it was a lot of
money and it was like months going by
and their um office i knew was like
really close to my old apartment and i
was like i'll come by and pick up the
check i literally sounded crazy
hold on payment
i'll just type out here
oh yeah okay here they kept saying the
check is in the mail which is like so
i'm like hi checking in again i said hi
this is getting ridiculous very unfair
payment is over a month payment is over
a month late i've been extremely patient
but this is outrageous no response i
wrote again any update here will payment
be processed in 2017 this year do you
have a date anything helpful
no response can you believe that
again oh then they write
i have your check apologies for the
delay i said thank you
what was it sent out
she goes
they were playing with me and then at
the end
she never responded she said yes you
should receive it next week next week
comes and said i'm doing my best to
remain patient but this is out of
control you've had the checkup you had
the check on tuesday it's monday my home
is less than five blocks from your
office i'm happy to come pick it up
because we'll need this squared away
before the holiday please assist
i finally do get the check
in the mail you went and got it in the
mail
she said we just sent it in the mail
today after she said she had it a week
ago liars and i'm like but you had it on
tuesday and said on friday it was
already sent out and now it's monday and
you're saying you're sending it out
i did eventually get it but that's how i
would handle it being really [ __ ]
annoying on email to answer your
question in
okay and then i never worked with a
brand again and honestly
that was their call not mine but like i
probably wouldn't have worked with them
again uh yeah no i'm looking forward to
finding out what brand this was yeah you
wanna tell you you could tell me offline
okay i'm gonna whisper to you
no that's like people hate when we do
that i really wanna say it but like i'm
not in the business of you know turning
down business just tell me
huh
oh wow that's surprising i know because
it's like literally a multi-billion
dollar brand and it had nothing to do
with the brand it was the agency and i
know this agency like extremely well
okay wow well thank you for that
personal anecdote you gotta get what's
yours you gotta get what's yours so i
understand like being but also like if
you're getting i guess it's tough
because like if he was getting covered
relief then he couldn't lay off his
tenant but his tenant wasn't paying rent
for a year and a half before that right
and now out of it i don't think the
covered relief still stands right and i
i doubt he's looking for four years
worth of rent i'm sure he's still
looking for like two years before covid
yeah
yeah
so
but it's it's like hard to lose your job
during covid right because the
government shut you down right
i don't know um so those are the best
five
you definitely need to know them yeah no
except for the regat we got you needed
to know
must know um but don't cry don't even
get sad because the show's not even
close to being over
it's unburdened yourselves time which is
our monday segment where you can write
in to unburden yourselves gmail.com and
tell us something embarrassing that
happened to you over the weekend that
you can't get out of your mind and we
will officially take that burden and on
it you know it feels good to share this
is a safe space we try not to judge
sometimes it's hard but i think we're
getting better
um and we just want to make you feel
better part of the process that's how we
end this burden we process it and just
come over here yeah that's how we let it
go give me your burden let me i will
carry it for you i will complain about
the weight and then i will set it down
yeah i mean we do we have three really
good ones and they're brought to you by
hungry root trying to eat a little
healthier feel a little better and have
an easier time in the kitchen we've
found the easiest way to do it and the
secret is hungry root hungry root is the
easiest way to get fresh high quality
food delivered to your door they've got
healthy groceries and simple recipes all
in one place a fun short quiz is all
hungry brew needs to get to know you
your goals and how you like to eat are
you gluten free noted do you like sweets
they'll keep it top of mind and get to
work hungry root will recommend
groceries that they think you'll love
take their suggestions or choose what
you want from their fresh produce high
quality meat and seafood pantry staples
and all the healthy snacks and sweets
you'll ever need you're not getting your
weekly grocery haul you can also shop
thousands of simple recipes that
actually put your food to use everything
hungry root offers follows a simple
standard it has to be delicious quick to
prepare and made from whole trusted
ingredients spend less time shopping and
cooking and more time enjoying healthy
food that you'll actually love with
hungry root right now hungry root is
offering the morning toast listeners 30
off your first delivery and a free gift
with every delivery just go to
hungryroot.com toast to get 30 off your
first delivery and choose your free gift
that's hungryroot.com toast don't forget
to use our link so they know we sent you
wonderful okay ready unburden yourselves
first up hey girls this show is truly
the only place where i can unburden
myself on this one
sometimes i get a burst of the wildest
diarrhea like topless sweating sitting
on the toilet crying for help it's
always so random so i looked up my up on
my phone why do i randomly get diarrhea
fast forward to saturday night when i
was out with my friends and this really
hawkeye and my friend group that i like
that i like to flirt with was asking me
questions about this festival we were
planning on going to
he took my phone to look something up
and i hadn't cleared my search from the
diarrhea questioning he announced the
search to the group and everyone was
making fun of me and i feel like i'll
truly never recover i'm mortified i hate
him like you didn't do anything wrong
you didn't do anything wrong and like
okay so it's embarrassing that he saw it
the fact that he announced it like
immature disgusting piece of [ __ ]
like i'm done with him yeah lesson
learned and the fact that your friends
laugh like get new friends yeah if
anything like you look like the hero in
this story you're the victim you know
you have diarrhea and everyone's making
fun of you when someone shows you who
they are believe them like we just got
an insight into what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
this guy is and you like to hang out
with him and flirt with him no not on my
watch not anymore no no no and i know
you didn't come here for advice just
like on the burden but you have
literally nothing to be embarrassed
about outside perspective to tell you
that these people are wrong for what
they did to you and they're not your
friends your friends should protect you
yeah
there's nothing to unburden like you
literally oh you had diarrhea sorry
you're human
like they should be worried not laughing
and at least you know what it shows that
you're like a really you know health
conscious queen looking up making sure
everything's going right with your body
there's nothing wrong with this like
literally your friends are just [ __ ]
set down this burden and please like
stop giving this guy the time of day fly
because only a loser would do that like
yeah big loser energy
ble i'm like mad on your behalf me too
like that's just not what you do like if
you see someone like what are we in 16
hours like something like embarrassing
like happening like
you don't expect you can't minimize it
like where you pretend like you didn't
see it like a normal person and move on
no these people are animals at least you
know it's a blessing yeah all right
hello my beautiful stunning and smart
queens i need to unburden this too so i
can stop panicking about it i work from
home and i'm a single girl living in a
one bedroom apartment so my living
workspace is tight my office is set up
in my bedroom yesterday i posted a
picture of my dog snoozing on my bed on
our company's pet slack channel because
he was looking like a precious crunchy
angel about five minutes later i went
back and looked at it clicked on the
picture and realized my nightstand was
in the background of the picture and my
vibrator was sticking out of my drawer
anyone with a brain would have been able
to tell what it was if they looked at
the picture i immediately deleted the
picture from slack but it was up for
about five minutes and multiple people
had reacted to it so i'm sure that they
saw that's all i'm never coming back
from it sincerely a girl who needs a
two-bedroom
okay
i don't think it's like that bad i don't
think it's that bad because if someone
like sent a picture of their dog i would
just see the dog only like a snoop
is looking for other things and you
could just pretend it's
something else yeah like in your head
it's a face squash off yeah yeah yeah
it's one of those like vibe you had a
clogged duck right people use vibrators
for their clogged in their breasts the
vibrator that i use for my clog like
definitely looks like a vibrator but if
you're not breastfeeding that that would
be hard to um what do they know yeah or
maybe someone's staying with you who is
breastfeeding maybe you're a doula on
the side like remember that like bed
head bottle um after party yeah the pink
the pink one like looked like a big
dildo it looked like a dildo yeah yeah
like just say it's like oh a hair
product that looks like a dildo lol the
thing is especially when it comes to
pets like people are really only
interested in looking at pictures of
their own pets so like whenever someone
like sends a picture i'm like oh my god
so cute you think i even open it up i'm
just like oh cute dog
most of the time people are so
self-involved with their own pets like
no one's really zooming in some people
do snoop and zoom in though some people
do
yeah honestly like i do often think like
when i send pictures like in my house
i'm like what is behind like is it dirty
underwear in the corner like i'm always
conscious of the background in my
personal home because like my home can
be disgusting sometimes so i feel this
and this is just one of those things you
have to learn the hard way yeah like now
every time you send a picture to anyone
from your home like you will just glance
around the background and make sure
that's like that picture that was like
going around that live photo of the girl
with the engagement ring and her
husband's dick in the back yeah yeah
like the photo is just of the engagement
ring but when you play it live
her husband whips out his penis his
penis is in it yeah live photos are not
your friend no
they are enemies and the only live
photos i appreciate are ones who send me
of harry because then i get like a
little action i get a four second clip
instead of just one picture yeah no but
you have to be
really careful like sometimes i'll take
a picture like
like if i was just breastfeeding like my
boob is out and like it's not in the
picture but like it could have been in
the lead-up no uh i've seen your nipple
like fixing no i'm not worried about
sending it to you but like if i'm
sending pictures around yeah yeah yeah
yeah then people want to play the live
nipple and sometimes the live photos
people settings have it to record audio
which is so scary so scary so just be
careful this is a lesson you have to
learn the hard way and it's not that big
of a deal so what people know you
exercise vaginal health like it's fine
it's like it's a gun you know like it's
fine it's fine it's just like because
it's work no it's just like awkward but
you know what like life is full of
awkward moments and that's just what we
have to accept when we leave our houses
you know yeah
and you know what just
put a burden down it happened to someone
else and it was your bed head after
party yeah and in the perspective of the
big bang theory
nothing nothing matters uh zoom in on a
photo yeah nothing it's a speck in the
time
landscape of history um okay this third
and final one is very special to me i
can't wait
hey besties you guys keep me standing on
my 30-minute commute as an icu nurse
love you love you love you thank you
i'm gonna make this short and sweet
simply because i went to my cousin's
wedding this weekend and i met my older
cousin's girlfriend for the first time
we live in different states and we
rarely get to see each other the wedding
was outside of atlanta at a farm and it
was quite literally infested with flies
and mosquitoes the awkward moment
between the ceremony and the reception
was in full swing and i found myself
alone talking to my cousin's girlfriend
when i noticed a large gray shape on her
shoulder i immediately went to flick it
off when she informed me that it was a
mole
the worst part is that
she told me it was a mole and i flicked
it again thinking it was a stubborn ass
bug i tried to cover my ass by saying i
just saw one flying by you she was so
sweet about it saying this happens all
the time but i can't stop thinking about
this moment i already feel better typing
this but i feel horrible for bringing up
her mole lol and trying to pull it off
her body
i get it i i get it
i think you played it off well by saying
no there was a little a fly yeah i mean
i used to have
like many moles and one of the ones that
brought me great grief was this one on
my neck and i'll literally never forget
like being a child and someone literally
telling me i had i got like chocolate on
my neck i'm like it's literally a mole
i'm gonna go to the bathroom now and die
but thanks yeah yeah this is like
probably mutually for the both of you
like i mean she wrote in her umbrella
right you know what at least your horror
and her horror can cancel each other out
i agree
i agree it's like when you think of all
the things you could have said like it's
not that bad it's not that bad i think
you played it off well all you can do
now is like set down the burden because
it's not serving you to carry it around
no and like while it is sad that you
live in a different state than your
cousin and never get to see him the
bright side is like you never have to
see his moldy girlfriend you know yeah
no and by the time you see her next like
this will just be in the rear view yeah
someone else will have done it to her
shoulder and like you won't be the most
recent person in memory to have flicked
her maul yeah
but you should change your name from
whatever it is hannah to the mole
flicker immediately
yeah but set it down everyone who wrote
in and everyone who wrote in this week
but we didn't get a chance to read it
what's all the collective burden is
take a minute
sit with it carry that burden it's so
heavy it's hurting your arms are sore
you're almost there you're walking now
bend from your knees so you don't hurt
your back and set the burden down you
release the burden into the ethers and
free yourself
from
the anxiety you're free you're free
freedom
freedom
i won't let you down freedom i will not
give you freedom
you gotta give what you take
well that's our show that was on burden
yourselves again if you want to write in
something horrifying that happened to
you unburden yourselves at gmail.com
love it thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast we are so
glad every time that you do it warms our
hearts it does
um subscribe
to our youtube
and the podcast for subscribing to the
podcast before i make you okay follow us
on instagram yeah we've been posting
premium content reels that will crack
you up and thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast
millennium morning show where we deal
with the fast life stories that you need
to know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
radio cast box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcast find us
the morning toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
incredible monday and we'll see you
tomorrow for
tuesday
tuesday friend or foe we'll discuss
tomorrow we'll have the answers on
tomorrow's show
you don't want to miss it this
groundbreaking research we'll see you
tomorrow morning goodbye
goodbye